and there was a leaked snapchat of you
and and cast member Sean oh there was
Bachelorette Kaitlyn Bristowe responds
to that infamous snapchat snafu did you
spoil the outcome of this season for
everybody I don't know did I difficult
Bachelorette keeping it coy but Kaitlyn
did have plenty to say after Monday
night's controversial episode she slept
with contestant Nick and it was all
caught on camera all the audio anyway I
did not know that every year but um I
think it was probably mics from the
camera cuz we didn't have Mike son and
was that awkward for you two last night
was was that a surprise for him it was
awkward yes
I was expecting some sort of backlash
but maybe not this much well she did get
backlash from Sean he basically flipped
when he learned that Nick had even been
to Caitlin's hotel room she ruined
everything that we had still when
talking about Sean
Kaitlyn couldn't stop smiling John is
obviously very hurt than upset by the
whole me having other relationships
which I get because we do have such a
strong connection and it's very obvious
to everybody did you find love on this
show are you in love I am very happy
with how it turned up very interesting
and Kaitlyn maintains she has no regrets
about her on-camera intimacy with Nick
if it was the bachelor I think people
would have already moved past it by now
Chris soules kissed everybody I'm not
sure why Chris gets that like all
Americans sweetheart and I'm like this
horrible human being what do you guys
think is Kaitlyn being unfairly judged
here and do you think Shawn the one she
chose let us know on twitter using the
hashtag t now
you